ouais on va parler évidemment bien sûr
de vos vacances les téléspectateurs vous
connaissent mais forcément ça ne peut
pas passer à côté j'ai vu là chez moi
j'ai vu la liste des chroniqueurs dont
j'étais comme ça comme ça j'étais sûr
mais ça je sais j'étais comme ça puis
j'étais comme ça et puis l'été la cei m
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais juste une question super me
regarde
est ce que je t'ai manqué
la pub est
ce que tu m'as manqué alors je retourne
voir serrer ses profs et des joies là et
après alors je te dis la vérité ayem tu
dis tout était dû à m ou tu reste pas là
parce que franchement là je veux la
vérité tu veux que je redevienne comme
comme tanger tous
les ans pose la question si ayem a
disparu depuis des années tu vis ou de
quoique quand est ce que faisait 32
valaisan de monsieur alain nault
tue-mouches batave a appris la nouvelle
alors je vis dans le sud ouais je me
suis retiré de parler je me suis un
petit peu il a reçu ce que j'avais
besoin d'accords avec qu'ils disent mais
avec mon site d'accord on en passe des
célibataires maman ces débats pc quoi
c'était
les gens veulent savoir nouvelle
d'accord ok et faustine bollaert est un
peu comme ça je cherche quelqu'un
mais c'est vrai les téléspectateurs pour
le coup de tête disparu pendant des
années et était même encore jonathan
instagram da quasiment un million de
personnes qui le sud oui les gens
t'aiment willis genthod c'est un
feuilleton la télé est donc tout d'un
coup tu as disparaît donc tu es parti
dans le sud avec ton fils enlevé suivi
qui était marié avec mogi vague avec un
calme un peu d'argent tu est divorcé un
peu
je n'avais en perte sur vous c'est une
question toute bête mon shoot de quoi tu
vis du divorce
non
c'était tout le sympa en leur
nom mais j'aimerais savoir c'est que
maintenant alors j'ai un jean je me suis
isolé et d'ailleurs tu es m'a conseillé
aussi un moment donné m'isoler et de le
prendre pas mal isolés
métier j'avais j'avais beaucoup de
colère il fut un temps j'écris un livre
j'ai pu tous occupés tout ceci signale
que l'appétit de maman pis on appelle ça
que j'avais un petit peu d'argent de
côté aussi d'accord même si et puis une
petite torture alimentaire et tout ça il
est vive à traduire à son intérêt pour
mon psy c'est la crème et rapide sur des
détails
c'est l'argent de mon fils